let's give a big welcome to Megan
Trainer and Jimmy
[Applause]
[Music]
Fallon
you can probably touch
them you're tall enough to touch them
wow what's that what's that like I'm
gorgeous here including the crowd
everyone happy Holidays happy holidays
neighbor I know neighbor you've been
here for so long so many years so like
what's the favorite Christmas moment I
love it here at Christmas time you enjoy
it cuz this is the busiest time of this
I don't mind it I love it I'm used to it
as well I mean I've been here for like
probably 25 years cuz I've been been
doing s live it looks so good thank you
I haven't
left traffic is terrible you can't leave
it's better to just stay here for 25
years I'm just planing your moments is
insane that's a lot of your life s live
yeah I mean everything it's most of my
life has been here so I mean with the
the tree uh lighting and by the way
great job hosting the tree lighting I
love that perfect perfectly done but
that that ice rink is fun I like to even
just go down and just watch people fall
it's just fun you don't you don't have
to ice G if you don't want to but I mean
that FAO is here now Toy Story it's just
everyone's in a good mood it's really
beautiful down there and great so I I I
I love this time of year I mean it
starts kind of with the parade too yeah
kind of kind of for us and and Macy's
Thanksgiving Day Parade and The Roots
and I have been doing it for 10 years
wow and uh wild it's so funny how some
Christmases since I've done the
Thanksgiving per before like as a singer
for different ones so funny cuz
sometimes it is fine the weather and
sometimes you are like ice what oh it's
freezing yeah well I think what's fun is
before the parade starts it's like
probably 6:00 in the morning you have to
get all get on a tour bus and wait to
get on the floats so that they all go in
the right time so you're on this bus
with a bunch of different people that
are on floats and sometimes you have
different people coming on the bus I
remember one year I was on the bus with
Ronald McDonald I was on that same bus
were you on that bus we were on the same
bus together I tell everyone that story
you do I say I was with Ronald
McDonald's yeah and he talks just like a
regular person you yell
he's trying to have a conversation he's
trying to have a conversation and he's
Ronald McDonald he's Ronald McDonald
he's drinking a coffee he's like oh man
traffic is terrible go yeah can't talk
to you man you're Ronald McDonald don't
R the Magic Ronald don't can't just go
and hi you're just be you yeah you in
New York at Christmas time I know you
love Christmas time like a me so what
are your kids into do you get do you
dress them up do you get like oh yeah
yeah this year I said all I want for my
birth birthday oh words are tough right
now all for my birthday is um a
full-blown photo shoot like a Christmas
edition and then like a regular photo
shoot because you're just so delicious
and cute right now Barry is and they
grow out of it so quickly Barry is five
months old when I was pregnant on here
Barry he's five months old Barry Barry
Barry is the name of the baby is that
the cutest name is that the best name
for a baby Barry that's the cutest thing
ever heard in my life star
star and then Riley's like two and a
half and he walks around the house every
day going wrap me up yeah he sings Our
Song and have little glasses yeah are
your kids still in it cuz you have the
Christmas book too are your kids still
in the Christmas the sleeps yes yeah
five more sleeps that's how my kids talk
I told you this before but they talk in
sleeps they're like how many more sleeps
until Disney World I stole that from my
daughter yeah I was taking her to school
and she goes how many more sleeps till
we go to uh noma's house or something I
go how many that's so cute how many more
sleeps so yeah so I put out that book
and then yeah it kind of took off I was
like all right this is great any IDE as
an adult my mom does that for me now
she's like two more sleeves two more SLE
you got this this I do that and time
that's not a kid thing that's a me thing
that's an everybody thing anyway like
how did this single start like how did
like wrap me up like how did y'all get
together for this s how did this happen
well we've a great guest of the show
Megan Trainer and so I loved you ever
since you first came on the show and so
I'm working on a comedy Christmas album
that's going to come out next year and
so I'm writing I heard that and so Megan
heard that and she goes uh I want to be
part of it she goes yeah she goes I want
to what do you got any ideas like I I'll
do something so I sent her a scratch a
voicemail from my phone and it's really
bad and this is kind of really tell me
if I'm wrong I was going like it was
called wrap it up and I
go wrap it up wrap it up wrap it up WP
it up WP it up anyways I didn't hear
back from Megan for six
months okay I think we're I don't know
why I don't know why uh and then I like
oh no she like how do I break it to him
is terrible uh no I fixed it yeah no I
was like I could do this what do I do
with this I was like doesn't he know
that I'm a do Up Gal and we should do
like a Christmas doop song and then I
cuz it sounds classic thank you and then
we made it like modern and fun too cuz I
was like you you may rap if you would so
wish to you know so he has his whole
verse big shiny balls all up on that
Christmas
tree about Christmas ornaments ornaments
Christmas ornaments Big Shiny big shy
yeah yeah so I there so many ways go
with that he should save it but we wrote
a good one it's we wrot a good one it's
called wrap me up and I was like okay
we'll we'll put it out let's put it out
this year just because it's too good to
hold for next year and then people
started playing it on the radio and I
know you guys know what it feels like
but as a comedian I don't know what that
feels like so I please stream it you're
a comedian but you sing really well so
that's the thing it's like you almost
could have had another career going on I
freaked out that people can can do it I
mean I I grew up listening to to
Christmas carols and stuff like that and
my sister it was really that she took
piano lessons she would play like three
songs like Dex three she knew Jingle
Bells yeah and I think silent I think I
can still remember Silent Night yeah you
should sing it I could sing it wait I
want to sing I'm going to maybe put you
on the spot for us all to sing but
before I do that I want to ask you
because I do also know that you were on
was it a holiday version of password
like on password there was like a
holiday version you episod it airs
December 18th password is back Kiki
Palmer is awesome she's the host it's
back but wait were yall competitive we
played against each other I know were
you competitive she little bit I think I
think I'm competitive Megan the table
Yeah and almost strangled
me so fun it's a holiday themed episode
John Cryer's on the show as well uh and
you're going to love it at airs after
The Voice finale on NBC it's good good
timing yeah that's amazing good timing
yeah what's like your favorite Christmas
song If you had pick one like a classic
anything by Michael blé and you oh I
love Michael blé I know I love he sounds
like he is Christmas that sounds I like
the Rett every year my parents play the
Rett like it's a great record that's
what my no maybe we should sing do you
you brought up silent night and I feel
like we're all three
singers we have a we have a
guitar oh no oh yeah here's here's the
best part there is been no rehearsal
we've never so this could go very poorly
but I feel confident we've never yeah
we've never done lien rehearses but
going to be great I don't know maybe G
maybe G okay you start and then we'll
chime in this is going to be great
[Music]
sure
Holy
[Music]
Night
all
is and
childly so tend
and sleep in
Heavenly
peace sleep in
that was for
[Applause]
you I love
that we are
talented that's our Trio for America
all right let's he some Megan j and
Jimmy once again Jimmy and Megan's new
holiday song is called wrap me up you
can listen wherever you get your music
we sounded so delicate as well and you
can see them on a special holiday
edition of password Monday December 18th
only on
[Music]
NBC
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home